[Música]
eu pensei muito sobre o que eu diria
hoje para essa platéia tão diversa a
respeito do profissional do futuro e
como professora me pareceu interessante
talvez discutir o que seria educar para
o futuro
tem várias abordagens que do abordagens
que poderiam ser dadas a isso
ultimamente quando a gente pensa sobre a
educação do futuro a maioria das pessoas
acaba associando isso algumas idéias
como por exemplo a nova sala de aula que
remetem ao design inovadores a
arquiteturas absolutamente diferenciadas
hoje a gente começa a falar um pouco
sobre novas técnicas de ensino e
aprendizagem então a gente reflete um
pouco a respeito de modalidades que
talvez fossem mais atrativas para uma
geração que já não se define da mesma
forma
ou quem sabe talvez a educação do futuro
em geral acaba sendo abordada em função
das transformações no campo da
tecnologia
eu pensava sobre tudo isso porque me
interesso por isso também acredito que a
grande avanço contribuições
significativas
nessas três áreas mas quando eu parei e
olhei bem pra mim eu disse a minha
experiência de educação do passado me
faz acreditar que não são essas coisas
que moldam a educação do futuro
e aí pensando sobre o que efetivamente
importa quando o assunto é educar no
passado hoje ou no futuro me ocorreu que
talvez o elemento mais importante ou
pelo menos o que me impactou mais como
aluna e depois como professora foram as
pessoas
foi gente então hoje eu vim aqui
conversar com vocês sobre o que eu acho
que a educação do futuro e essa educação
passa necessariamente por
relacionamentos eu vou tentar contar
essa história
a partir de uma imagem que talvez alguns
aqui já te conheço
a expectativa
eu me tornei professora com 21 anos
professor universitário e toda vez que
eu pensava sobre o porquê de ter tomado
essa decisão eu lembrava de alguém que
tem impactado o meu caminho de pessoas
de professores do meu passado era de
certa forma um desejo de ver o mundo
pelos olhos deles era de certa forma uma
tentativa de ser esses professores um
dia e quando eu fui convidada para me
tornar professora a primeira preocupação
que me passou pela cabeça foi como eu
paramentaria minha sala de trabalho o
que eu ia botar lá de decoração e eu
optei por essa foto que vocês hoje vem
como eu disse à lusa que são familiares
já vir outras vezes essa foto ela é
muito simbólica pra mim por dois motivos
em primeiro lugar porque quando eu optei
por utilizá lá na minha mesa de trabalho
eu pretendia que com ela eu sempre me
lembrasse de onde eu vim e das pessoas
que tinham feito parte dessa trajetória
e além disso essa uma foto que tinha
como objetivo também é transformar as
relações com os meus próprios alunos em
relações mais pessoais
ela tinha a função de quebrar o gelo ela
tinha função de até soar um pouco
adequada
a idéia é que as pessoas se incomodassem
com a presença dessa foto numa sala de
trabalho e de lá pra cá
toda vez que eu tive a experiência de
conversar com os meus alunos a frase que
mais me marca toda vez que eu estou com
ele
é a idéia do eu queria ser você porque
foi a frase que eu também repetir os
meus professores e aí a gente olha para
esse mundo que é um mundo difícil
perigoso é da sociedade de risco do ibec
é do panóptico do focou é da vida
líquida do baú
num mundo de inconstância ao mundo de
insegurança o mundo em que as coisas
perderão a forma e se depara com a
tecnologia se depara com as novas
metodologias e esquece da gente esquece
que a sala de aula eo relacionamento da
educação é necessariamente um
relacionamento interpessoal
isso não vai mudar nunca então pensando
um pouco nisso eu tentei elaborar aqui
quatro pilares que segundo a minha visão
são expressões da educação do futuro e
que de certa forma fazem sentido a
partir da minha história
não porque tenha ido buscar nos dados
essas informações ou porque eu tenha
feito uma análise rigorosa do ponto de
vista metodológico mas porque eu sei que
vem da legitimidade da sala de aula das
relações cotidianas de todas as vezes
que houve eu queria ser você
o primeiro ponto desses quatro pilares
têm a ver com a horizontalização das
relações e não é só uma questão
geracional porque essa geração que vem
agora seja lá o nome que ela receba ela
não respeita a hierarquia da maneira
tradicional não é isso tem a ver com
como a gente constrói legitimidade a
legitimidade da educação hoje e no
futuro não é a legitimidade construída
pelos títulos não é a legitimidade
construída pela aparência nem quem sabe
pelo status a legitimidade da educação
eo que cria conexão é a percepção de que
você pode melhorar a alguém e você pode
melhorar alguém porque você tem algo a
dizer
pra mim não existe pensar a educação do
futuro sem considerar que a educação
passa necessariamente pela capacidade de
criar conexões
isso nos leva ao segundo pilar que tem a
ver com o conhecimento interpretado como
sendo universalista
porque a gente foi treinado quando
ensina quando aprendi a olhar para o
mundo cercado de muros como se o que
acontece do lado de lá não fosse um
problema nosso
só que o conhecimento que leve em conta
as relações ou de certa forma a educação
que contemple os relacionamentos ela
interdisciplinar como a vida porque a
vida interdisciplinar e tudo passa a ser
problema seu
eu acredito que a educação do futuro ou
educar do futuro passa também pela
percepção de que fomos nós que
construímos esses muros e que esses
muros são tão artificiais que fariam
leonardo da vinci passar vergonha esses
muros nos fazem esquecer que as maiores
lideranças os intelectuais mais
brilhantes de todos os tempos foram
intelectuais que contribuíram da
astrologia matemática da filosofia do
direito
foram cidadãos que olharam para a
realidade e perceberam que havia um
potencial transformador que não se
enquadrava na estrutura curricular que
não estava contemplado dentro de uma
questão múltipla escolha e que nem
estava limitado pelo número de dias
letivos
pra mim o terceiro pilar da educação do
futuro passa pela liderança pelo afeto
porque se as relações foram
horizontalizados e só assim é que se
constrói a legitimidade
então qualquer liderança jamais vai ser
reconhecida
jamais vai ser respeitada se não assumir
o seu caráter empático se não for capaz
de demonstrar afeto e dedicação porque
nós vivemos tempos difíceis em que a
maioria das pessoas simplesmente não se
importa
então é educar é também segundo a minha
visão para agora e para o futuro uma
demonstração de afeto e sem afeto não é
possível
as conexões e horizontalizar as relações
e olhar para o mundo como sendo
interdisciplinar e finalmente a educação
do futuro educação de propósito porque
nós somos levados a acreditar que o
futuro carece de significado
aliás talvez a gente perca tempo demais
pensando no futuro talvez nós estejamos
o deixa nos deixando colonizar pelo
futuro
e toda vez que a gente pensa muito sobre
o futuro esquece do sentido de propósito
a gente faz coisas que simplesmente não
levam a lugar nenhum com a educação
também é assim
a gente só aprende aquilo que a gente
acha que significa alguma coisa e que dê
certo
de certa forma atende ao que nós temos
como segundo a nossa visão enquanto
propósito a gente só faz aquilo naquilo
que a gente acredita
aquela fonte da ovelha que vocês viram
no começo ela ocupa a minha sala de
trabalho há quase dez anos
eu mudei de sala de trabalho várias
vezes de lá pra cá mas o que não mudou é
que toda vez que olho para ela eu tento
me lembrar dessas duas coisas das nossas
origens e também da idéia de que
enquanto educadores
nós temos que romper os muros
semana passada eu fui surpreendida pela
manifestação de dois alunos que eu
gostaria de homenagear aqui pra fazer
esse encerramento dos alunos com
histórias muito difíceis difícil de
verdade
histórias que dizem respeito à vida e
morte histórias que dizem respeito à
pobreza à miséria a violência
uma dessas alunas deixou sobre a minha
mesa um desenho feito em guache num
papel cartão era um céu escuro estrelado
no verso havia escrito
pra você que sempre quis que eu visse as
estrelas na mesma semana um aluno me fez
uma música que o refrão da música que
ele escreveu dizia assim a educação é a
luz time empurra da maldade pura bondade
pra mim isso a educação do futuro
educação do futuro é a educação que cria
conexão que passa pelo afeto que tem
significado de mudas vidas e que nos faz
lembrar que o futuro é só uma orientação
e não o nosso colonizador
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]